sehr geehrter herr bundeskanzler
ich freue mich sehr
mal treffen sie kennenzulernen und in
moskau empfangen
möchte direkt betonen dass die
bundesrepublik einer unserer wichtigsten
partner überhaupt in europa insbesondere
ist
ist das unser größter wirtschaftlicher
art und landes partner und ich möchte in
dem zusammenhang auch betonen dass trotz
aller schwierigkeiten in dem zeitraum
hatten wir im letzten jahr eine kleine
korrektur des warum umsatzes um mehr als
36 prozent ist er gewachsen und das ist
natürlich ein
hunderte von unternehmen
arbeiten zusammen
milliarden dollar wurden die russische
wirtschaft investiert und die russischen
unternehmen über 10 milliarden dollar
auch investiert das ist auch eine gute
investition in die entwicklung der
deutschen wirtschaft und dem schaffen
von arbeitsplätzen
kommen wir unsere beziehungen viel
diversifiziert und sie entwickeln sich
auch in unterschiedlichen bereichen aber
natürlich es ist traditionell und hat es
sich natürlich entwickelt dass
einer der prioritären bereiche ist ich
werde jetzt nicht alle zahlen auf pisten
sehr wohl bekannt wir können dann später
und beim pressegespräch darüber nochmal
sprechen aber auf jeden fall ist ein
zuverlässiger lieferant von
energieressourcen seit langem nicht seit
jahrzehnten machen wir das und es gab
während dieser jahrzehnte kein einzelnes
lieferprobleme
energielieferungen aus russland alles
basiert auf markt prinzipien
es gibt hier überhaupt keine fragen
keine zweifel
als partner kennen wir einander mann
sehr lange auch die unternehmen und es
ist viel gegenseitiges vertrauen da und
wir haben auch die entscheidung
getroffen
eigentlich
ja deutsche partner an unserer
wichtigsten aktiver gelassen auch
verdienst sondern von
der lieferung transporten unsere
unternehmen arbeiten in der
bundesrepublik wir haben auch viele
andere bereiche wie ich schon gesagt
habe aber zweifellos
ist einen großteil unserer zeit
der situation in europa gewidmet die mit
der sicherheit zu tun hat und mit den
diskussionen die aktuell so
dringend sind
auch was die geschehnisse rund um die
ukraine angeht all dies ist für uns sehr
interessant für beide seiten ich freue
mich sehr sie zu sehen
kurzem habe ich hier ihren französischen
kollegen empfangen wir haben diese
themen auch ausführlich diskutiert ich
weiß dass er sie informiert hat über
die bei unserer diskussion aufgekommen
sind
es wäre für mich sehr nützlich sehr
hilfreich auch ihre eigenen bewertungen
der geschenk zu hören nochmals herzlich
willkommen ich freue mich sie zu sehen
danke ich freue mich auch dass unsere
gespräche zustande kommt zu kurz nach
dem beginn meiner zeit als kanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland es ist etwas
besonderes mit der geschichte der
beziehungen zwischen deutschland und
russland vor dem hintergrund dieser
geschichte ist es gut dass wir sehr
ordentliche wirtschaftliche beziehungen
haben wie sie berichtet haben und dass
sie sich auch gut weiterentwickelt haben
natürlich ist klar dass wir jetzt in
dieser zeit war die schwierige situation
was frieden und sicherheit in europa
betrifft zu sprechen haben wir sind es
ja auch schon mit meinem französischen
amtskollegen getan haben aber ich bin
froh dass das jetzt möglich ist und dass
wir darüber sprechen können denn das
wichtigste ist ja das wäre die beziehung
zwischen den staaten durch gute
gespräche miteinander lösen und dass der
weg ist geht es geschieht